hello everyone and welcome to a now
playing of the banner saga I'm Tomic
Shay it was just a hey Walt and we're
gonna be playing some battering Saugus
we're gonna sagar some banners yeah this
is uh this is a Kickstarter game it's
like did you back this on Kickstarter
I'm back to this but I haven't gotten
the chance to play yet oh this is one of
them to see this this will be my first
time actually watching the game after
doing it just seeing the arts toilet is
what got me to back to kick start this
game and it is an absolutely beautiful
looking game and I really am looking
forward to seeing more of this cool
we're just gonna we're gonna start this
right from the beginning so you uh so
people aren't confused by the story and
we'll start out so are you gonna read
the story longer do I'm gonna read it
out loud with different voices the hold
on well that that only just missed it
you should do it like a dramatic
Patrick's my boys the gods are dead this
in their wake man and giant survived
through a tenuous Alliance driving black
destroyers called dredge deep into the
northern wastes now as an error of
growth and trade life goes on only one
thing has stopped the Sun dun dun dun
dun dun dun so uh as we see that stoic
made it we're giving away copies of this
game we are if you follow us on Twitter
um if you tweet out to a beam spot yeah
don't tell them how to do it yet Oh tell
me all right to keep an eye on Twitter
we are going to be giving out doing it
soon three copies of the game I was just
getting people and ready so they know
what to expect I know well that's only
half of it will tell you it a little bit
will tell you in a little bit oh yeah do
but there will be a way to win copies of
this game the deluxe digital edition
which also comes with the the soundtrack
by Austin wintery who is a famous
composer who did some of this s is
bridged games um turning it in Monaco
last year I think we're talking over the
game
several days ago the sun simply came to
a stop in the sky see that's how you boy
that well during these long winter days
none of us can be certain how long it
has been this way some of the man in the
caravan have taken it as a tired old man
I am NOT quick to superstition but I
myself will be glad to be done with this
year's rounders we have been warned by
stranded travelers about brigands on the
path through which horn our road home
our captain seems unconcerned perhaps he
is as eager as I to be done here we will
rest you this day and inquire further
when we speak to the governor little bit
of dude in the back how far back is we
need to catch up he's gonna be a wall no
old yeah I'll give you all have world
that dudes horn her name is Joe
okay so there there's a brief tutorial
that we have to go through but its brief
so you've already played through this
part of what what kind of game is its
what what should people expect it's a
it's not a tactic scam I know you
mentioned tactics earlier it's not
tactics but it's a detective now you
said tactic I you're making things well
okay so it's uh I mean it's a strategy
RPG that's basically it so I know what
are you doing exactly so what's going on
is that you I mean you move obviously on
a grid and you can move wherever it's
blue or you can use willpower to move
where it's yellow basically so you can
see there's blue and yellow so you can
move it a little further if you want
like I'm gonna do right there that's
what's teaching me and then you can
attack either they're they're weak tasty
body or you can attack their armor and
like armor makes the second if you do
more attack when you take the body
directly so I don't know that makes
sense right yeah so I mean it looks like
a tactic scheme but a little bit more
action focused how so because you're
clicking things what that's it is the
only that's purely the only reason I
said that oh is it turn-based it is
turn-based okay I've no idea what you're
talking about so what haha looking is
this most like aa college it stop it is
real life
how did it come to this we fool
ourselves believing that peaceful lust
my grandfather built all this from a
poor fishing village you know he wants
the gods dying what's the chaos that
followed what's man and bar distorted
each other even before the threads arose
all we've done is traded one struggle
for another now the Federal Motor edge
to war against the war against ourselves
this chieftain meant to kill me and he's
not the first a dozen families in the
city would gladly take my chair this one
had men wailing merchants both north and
south of the city strongly trade quite
well I do that though he denied it to
his lust this sort of all doesn't stop
biting because the head is cut off it
just grows her new hair
I'm in a bad way my friend helped me
finish this fight on out luckily sent
you on your way with doorbell our Kings
type take any man you meet then why am I
promise you that they will meet you down
into proving grounds so you play the
giants in this you're not playing the
little puny been but you recruit cuny
men too why would you want puny man when
you're a huge giant dude because you've
got like there's only a few Giants and
you need some help
so most I mean this game is a lot of
story in choices like mass effect level
choices I guess they're not they're more
subtle than that so dude is a steward
which means he's a cook heavily I don't
think that's what steward means you mean
is it stable boy he manages the
governor's business might actually what
he does yes he's called me up in so what
do you want me to stay here you want me
to be polite cuz when i was playing at
my desk i was being a real real jerk you
should probably be a real jerk just like
you are in real life I don't know I
usually play the game is really nice
though I know why why do you have to
role play you should play who you are in
just future you smack people around I'll
just say that one people don't know this
in real life tom is he rules with a
heavy hand no no just walks around
smacking left to right
governor tells me you'll be giving us a
hand oh yeah our picture in picture is
in the is covering all of the words
there's no way it is so the governor
tells me you'll be giving us a hand and
I get to choose what I'm going to say uh
seems a bit chaotic around here what did
you have in mind I didn't exactly agree
I'll Thomas seems a bit chaotic around
here because it does it's been worse
we've got a lot of irons in the fire
look at that it is right over it I'm
trying to push it away we can't push it
away it's not working what exactly what
does he want exactly scaffoldings that
you didn't pack up in the Great Hall
scattered after you took out their
chieftains the governor just wants to
make sure they stay down was hoping you
join me at the marketplace by the docks
that's not Shady there's anyone left to
worry about I know who can tell us so
you're gonna go look for sailors
basically this is Shenmue 3 so here we
are walking slowly spiritual successor
yeah hi um go or I could just
immediately go to the more these are the
little tricks that work let me handle
this that's what the looks like I is
steward yeah you render me it's like the
steward of gondor in Lord of the Rings
also we I don't have to read this all
out anymore right they can see this now
we meander stick Rosa pool houses and
eroded skulls irons in the fire eh
sounds promising says she Paui not in
the mood today for what talking to an
idiot oh snap i guess that when you have
rubber bands in your beers you are
considered an idiot just like Lou once
that dudes name captain lou albano Lou
Ferrigno no captain Lou albano not Lou
Ferrigno you used to play The Incredible
Hulk scaffoldings cheaper than blood out
about an hour ago so when you tell me
that whoa rat anus what
yeah I know you're paying attention I
don't talk to date they don't talk to me
what is the choice that we should i
could say do you need some help here I
don't have the patience for this or just
be the strong silent type what do you
think the twitch channel is saying he
needs to trim his antlers thanks for the
insight oh yeah well there is a bit of
delay with twitch because I which put
that in there I don't know the patience
for this he's fumbling with dirty
trinkets I think you're gonna act this
just a little food money yeah just a
little food way so I can intimidate him
pay him or do nothing intimidated I'm
gonna intimidate him just like real life
emotion to gun off your enormous
bodyguard who looms over the man like a
snake over a mouse or a moose God's
Erich laying it on a bit heavy don't you
think if I had different voices I think
he's coming on to you trying different
voices where this I can't do voices that
was months ago last I know and skulks
away with a wave of Eric's hand
gathering things from his hovel
disappearing for a while until this
blows over a figure your body cards hard
body got steps for why can't you read
this are we done here I'll read some
like a good old were you wearing green
back at the great hall I'm still got no
I just bought him while you were walking
around why definitely saying oh you look
like a frog ya feel very frog better
than an eggplant ah snap gun off goes
off to look at more stalls that's my
bodyguard we should decide who's gonna
read ah you should be open zombie ubben
Eric that man of yours seems unreliable
at best
a blind dog wouldn't trust had but he
used to be scaffolding if they're
licking their wounds they've probably
gone to old haunts not new ones that's
my ninja to rolls-royce nomadism is a
mead hall best I can tell his name is
ironic the name whatever the name of the
mead-hall is nobleman listen I know a
guy who would love to put a few of these
skulls in the ground I'm gonna find him
I'll meet you there should we have an
approach of some sort where's this place
again after this I'm done here I'm gonna
say we have approached that's all you
what a luxury come on you've already
mopped up worse today just make sure the
governor remembers his promise double
the usual tip tie ties haha all reminded
I think I bet my voice yeah we're not
good with voices this is what I'm
learning we're not voice actors we're
definitely not boys active so there we
are walking and now we're gonna go to
the meat house I think this is probably
a good time to remind player but remind
our Watchers our listeners that you can
win a free copy the game you totally can
you can't we tell again we are giving
away three copies of the game if you are
following us on Twitter unfortunately
this is not through the the twitch
stream but if following us on twitter if
you tweet at gamespot at stewart games
and use the hashtag banner saga that's
hashtag ba n n er sa GA you probably
know what that is if you're watching
this stream because it's really to the
game if you do all three of those things
keep an eye on our Twitter stream and we
will be given out a digital deluxe copy
of the game so when we announce it on
Twitter when we say something on Twitter
go ahead tweet at those three things
reply at them and you'll be put in the
running to win one of three digital
deluxe editions of the game that we're
given out at gamespot and still games in
hashtag banner saga okay you arrive in
front of what must be nobleman a few
minutes later Eric appears with a
weather-beaten man introduces valla
guard I'll point them out eric says over
shoulder ready we can get it over with
your walking through the front door or
rather sit this out i said this one out
let's get it over with that's the spirit
okay I'll here let's go so we are going
to do more fighting
valguard boots open the front door of
bun boots the front door open so hard it
won't close again without repair as you
entered the hall eric is already at the
head of a table his axe drawn wide-eyed
drunken scowling scrambled to find their
own weapons turning tables and Mead
Stein's in the process donk donk done
boo guru and now we are fighting so we
got cut off earlier because there was
acting going on what game does this this
most medic you played a lot of game
which one would you must compare this to
i don't know i mean i don't know i don't
think that's again i don't want to
then I go not report is a God of War is
that we're gonna go with call duty
definitely I got a war a call dude okay
so we're going to start this thing so
you set up your your troops before you
start you can kind of setup I guess a
strategy on how you're going to approach
these guys yes i will use don't know
Leslie and Stonewall is that just
putting up your shield is that an actual
spell I believe it is just putting up
your shield does a little less damage is
there any magic in this game it seems
kind of rounded it somewhat well I kind
of young can rally yeah that's magical
right rallies I know so it always as far
as the turns ago they are always my turn
your turn my turn your turn so even
though they are outnumbering us severely
we still get to go you know every other
time which is pretty convenient oh no he
dipped away some of my armor and then
some of my blood that wasn't good so
we're gonna hurt him someone says a one
person in the twitch chat says if I had
to say disgaea if only for the art style
comparison you disagree with that
rebuttal does not look like this guy at
all is this glory at all uh the gore is
from what I know from what i know i mean
i haven't played a ton but this is the
gore know a little bit of so there's you
know I mean this is rena red numbers
flying everywhere
well no it's not it's not just the red
numbers there's blood watch 32 my only
doing one damage to that dude I'm only
doing one damn it you need to do some
push-ups personal it's like not much
damage I'm gonna do I'm gonna do that
damage okay so i did not see any x so no
blood because i didn't attack the body
that time so when I count the next time
it'll be with a purpose so now I'm going
to kill this dude and watch what happens
when I kill already dead you saw that
blood burst out of his a valley region
right I mean it's not on the level of
mortal kombat but a little gory a little
bit of blood a little bit of blood blood
I don't want to be there she's like a
bad idea what if I just stand still and
attack the dude who's there that's gonna
kill him he was gonna do nine and he's
got sick well I mean you are a giant
dude with horns see how he died and then
you'll get promoted which is not how I
get promoted in real life I hitting
people with a sword yeah that's not
really how it goes the music and this is
is very it sets the tone I I'm doing
what town is that battle battle daddles
not a tone the tone of death a deputy a
death eat own
I don't know if that's the challenge so
this dude has a six health and I can do
one this dude has eight health and I can
do why are you such a weak dude
what if I do I don't wanna so if i do
that i do the willpower stuff and then
do three I guess what do you do so that
was using some my will power which gives
you can do further and oh he heard his
own dude willpower let you move a little
further or do next year tax i basically
did two attacks instead of one that time
so I could do more than my week one hit
point hurts Eric tape points out that
the reason that you did one attack point
is cuz it's early in the game dude geez
I guess that's true what can I do I
can't already actor willpower I can only
do the four I can't actually make it go
higher also in the [ __ ] that we get
this music says here i am rock you like
a hurricane to me i agree with that
that's actually not yeah that's not bad
not bad what is this guy gonna do i
attack i can do five damage which is
gonna kill him dead he didn't even have
a chance to not die because I killed him
dead I like how there are all these
dudes just sitting around watching you
guys one guy even has his feet propped
up on the table is like yeah all that is
totally happening like what what up this
is fun some other guys by the buffet
table chowing down watching the fight
and then like there's the dead body next
to the pig at the bottom yeah I do
doesn't have as much help as I wish he
had
they do not care who doesn't care all
the people are on the outside they're
not they're not cheering they're very
apathetic but now I'm fluff by this
Aaron nonplussed by yer your antics well
whatever oh no I dude got did he get
deaded how he got indented ah that's not
what's supposed to happen so this game
doesn't have permadeath this is not like
a fire of them awakening thing for you
lose these guys permanently is it I
don't know what if I lost them
permanently we only have to reset
startup we're not gonna do that for this
dream yeah all right now but Wow in
permadeath games are you the kind of guy
that resets each time oh you just go
with it you're like they're dead they're
going on I wrote about that like final
act exclusivos I game fire emblem I
wrote about fire emblem being awesome
last year because it is awesome I wrote
about XCOM and Fire Emblem because I
like Burma dessin games cuz it's not
dumb and then tonight I like punishment
games
like some kind of punished so you're
kind of a masochist no I'm not I it's
like if you played a game with a
controller that shocked you a little bit
whenever you die did you is that such a
bit more probably not but it's like you
know one games to be too easy it's not
it's not even it's not even necessarily
a difficulty thing because I don't think
a lot of games that have some sort of
punishment or difficult but it's just
like if you don't have any difficult if
you don't have any punishment than I
don't have any fear of acting like an
idiot that was one of my problems was
like the last of us has like no the
checkpoints or every like like two
minutes basically like that that kind of
thing is really frustrating so I really
appreciate something like you know Dark
Souls the customer what am i rambling
are guys in the ditch that says there is
permadeath in the dialogue in combat
they will not die so you can lose people
through the choices that you make in the
story but not necessarily through the
mistakes you make in combat but the bad
choices I make to do died in my combat
there they are well that's you that's
you
I'm gonna do a different ways there they
are gods-be-damned I've got to go wash
off this blood eric is looking at the
halls windows into the bay a fleet of
longships approach with sales of old
reds and blues one banner I know well
bog near next for vorel kinship last we
spoke the other flag looks important
yeah important guests see what I deal
with all day long ah things make a
little more sense you hoped I'd have a
stake in saying everything's fine here
when the royal guests arrived not me the
governor is he's a steward he's the guy
who gives the governor a bath each
morning now I have to make sure there's
no rotting bodies or pools of entrails
still in the Great Hall before they come
by not bad can I ask one more favor what
ah I know they know or what is it I'll
say what is it if you happen to stall
our guests down on the docks I wouldn't
object maybe I will Anakin vulgare
hustle from the meat house to his credit
annick tosses the bar give a spar of
silver for the mess you give an
apologetic shrug and go to greet the new
arrivals down on the docks and I grade
them with my fist or with my tongue with
your butt it was my butt to bug greeting
you know you touch butts like little hop
in the air and a butt touch what's your
prediction though my fighting them are
talking to him talking walk near click
familiar viral steps onto the docks in
your mind you recall a much younger
version tramping the halls of Richfield
abundant and purpose
go on Subin you're looking ancient comes
with being old and if there is bogner
there must be Huckle cotton ball up own
[ __ ] talking mush they're still
bleedin tributes on the foreign stupid
old yocks it won't age dear loser since
a shame ah Howard sucks surrender
gerander yearned their demands it I'll
take that over lingering to to death and
Ralph I'm speaking of I have no sense
that you were so far from home just
returned from ehrenberg in fact
seriously his slave and glad for it he's
changing up a little hocking motions to
the other ships in the bay sales still
fluttering golden wolf head and blazoned
on red the king of men or someone else
on his behalf the King's well the Sun
the king's son duden don't you know
Scrivener we visit his capital he visits
hours it's how you make alliances these
days whose [ __ ] we haven't thought he
hasn't done it yet now you do you're
hoggin mocking your Hawking in bargain
or whatever it is it's a miserable waste
of time this gets a better job hasn't I
don't lose for Dalton it's a good thing
you're around Hawking then you're going
to growth him let's delete I have the
distinct feeling I finished my business
and strand and was headed there myself
we should caravan we showed caravan give
it a day in better circumstances I drink
a week away but uh let's just be done
find me tomorrow at the gates what he's
trying to say is the princes a delight
to behold
where's murder hakan heaven find a place
to put up the Warriors I'm headin to
meet the governor host of giants depart
in his wake you recognize a few others
are strangers to you guess I'm off to
find moguer see in the morning scribner
Oh Omaha the young prince of men ambles
from his ship he brushes off his tunic
scanning the beach with low eyelids
luton looks for all the world the sort
of boy who grew up pulling the legs from
spiders how do you look like that that's
I don't want to look like that the long
road back to Groff I'm should be more
interesting than most years using so
that reminds me of my favorite
description in JD Salinger's book nine
stories there's a story called before
the war the Eskimos and the the girl
through his perspective looking at like
a teenage boys goes he looks as though
he may have attempted to shave
left-handed at some point which is so
perfect that's my favorite does that
mean his face is just scars oh my god he
just I don't he'll he's kind of
nonchalant and show off e I guess and
weariness suddenly settles in and you
chuckle to yourself about what an odd
day it has been one of the governor's
men at the Great Hall could find you a
place to sleep on the other hand if
you're going to join Wagner's caravan
tomorrow might not hurt to share a drink
with [ __ ] or introduce yourself for
the Prince they spoke so highly of
so who's that which ones which I is that
me going to sleep I don't know I feel
like I wish the portraits popped up more
frequent like just every time there was
a name so who do you think I go to this
one you should go two horny the horny
guy I don't wanna go then go to the Y
even asking well there's also the great
hole there's three choices right place
this the twitch chat says Tom Lee and
out some literary references well Tom
make a Hemingway comparison during the
spelunky run tune in to find out you
never know you never know you got to
read this you find the prince at an end
guards blanket the building including
the sharp-eyed Varro who must be working
for looting a woman in red eventually
waves you over it stands nearby arms
crossed greetings Prince luden you're
with Faulkner I don't remember you not
exactly i've known wagner a long time
I'll be joining you back at gruffly with
my guards lunatics up for the first time
the woman doesn't react that's that's
what happens to me every time as well no
reaction from the women relationship
jokes okay why that's what yes your line
oh I work for the king carrying tithes
to the capital tits times we crossed by
chance Oh a tax collector fine company
sarcasm what do you want introduce
myself I hope you learn more about you
have a habit of recording history I
thought we might talk about your visit I
don't know recording history I thought
we might talk about your visit that's
what I'm gonna I'll that's what you have
to say that's why just said it you're
saying that say we're gonna do that one
I thought I was saying that I don't know
son I didn't Ave oral historian aha
don't you already know your king and
mine both have been practically
trumpeting it throughout the cities I've
been on the road a while I'm afraid
louddon takes a deep sigh whether tired
or ungracious you aren't certain maybe
both probably both
i vouldn't a formality mostly near king
Dora capital in a barang and now we go
to the world's capital in Groff I'm to
submit this grand alliance for the next
age of men and viral or viral I don't
know they said that really casually at
first I don't know it viral you sound
unconvinced is that like the governor's
boy there's no need for it and it's damn
cold up here there's like no son you get
the cincy struggling not to complain
outright you take the opportunity to
excuse yourself I'll get my eyes move I
know it's really cute and then there's
like that wind blowing around the the
chesty reason there goes in the chesty
region this chassis the wind blowing his
hair I guess I can do both things I
wasn't really a choice I'm gonna talk to
the horny man squeeze not like Bartleby
the Scrivener yeah no preference
literary I know I never know I never
finished moby dick but I totally rad
barleys River you find hacking in a meat
house surrounded by other viral I think
Varro lure the horny guys strand is no
stranger to viral but rarely sees this
mini packin waves you over oh yeah they
say in the twitch chat moral equals
horny guys went straight for a floggin
flagon flagon like I'm drinking out of
wagon how can you make literary
allusions and then go flat flagon I
don't I don't know I I don't know words
I the thing is I'm referencing don't
have flagons of them flagon a flagon I
don't what is a horn of ale is that a
little horn yeah they used to drink out
of horns that's that's weird i don't i
probably have to make something to
support it maybe that's but yeah they
mention latin game a--the or of song of
ice and fire a lot and I'm always like
is that like what I think it is food
nears the one who agreed to pass up a
Drake I wasn't invited to the governors
hall anyway I don't know I'm Scottish
now instead of a pirate but whatever you
already missed the mess occur I was
gonna say mascara oh that's all his eyes
are they accuse a little mascara to pop
a little bit every year I make the
rounds collecting taxes every year it's
the human settlements that give me
trouble
no surprise what's this time know what
this time what this time but I got here
the Great Hall is already full of bodies
we added a few more ha humans I guess if
I only lived as long as our rocks fart I
might be desperate to make something of
myself too it's not too late to start
trying hakan packin Hawkin let's slip a
low chuckle and heave oral could recount
his deeds known as he is for cutting a
swath through dredge at bog near side in
the second war and regularly since then
down here I'm a glorified bodyguard you
might have a point just another reason
to get back to graphite soon enough I
imagine this is a chat hate us right now
or love only love the voices ok are you
just saying that not all having somebody
said that earlier ok someone said
someone likes it someone has said it you
drink until the meat house becomes
overbearing the step back into the cool
air outside someone also points out that
if you have not drinking out of a horn
you clearly haven't been to a ren faire
just saying I'm into ren fair and also
you eat a big turkey leg how those
things are the best I don't know where
they get them from turkey legs Turkey's
but turkey lays aren't even that are
they like their own to be that big
that's terrifying they are massive fide
turkey I live right next to Turkey
sometimes they're not always there's a
free-roaming turkeys and all that big a
dawn you are looking by a delivery of
goods least you think it's dawn what how
would you day they probably don't have
watches it's hard to tell oh it's hard
al this is the Sun damn damn hard to
tell in that Sun never moves they notice
the governor's crest adorns the supply
leathers and the all they're just as
promised to your mild surprise you
wonder if Eric had anything to do with
that clear them walk across the bottom
of screen they're walking I got her down
there guards take the treasure wagon
down to the gates vagnie r is already
here a while later luden and his men
appear groggy and dishevelled they were
in the whorehouse I'll it oh god it
might have been
berger steps forward vulgar
quartermaster if you recall correctly in
charge of hits his unwieldy entourage of
warriors you knew him only in passing he
asked if you're right it apart my only
choice is say we're ready I I think we
have to depart you follow moger and join
the others usually the smaller dorset
into the gates would be enough to enter
or leave the city but the town guards
have been told to push them open
entirely they mutter things under their
breath that are best not heard perhaps
the governor expected you would to a
draw a crowd perhaps the governor
expected you to draw a crowd but there's
nothing of the sort just frustrated
tired people it summarizes strand well
as a whole you think Punk don't don
there's the banner that the saga is
being pulled about right there someone
in the twitch chat says at first glance
i thought this justin fellow is Chris
waters Chris waters is about two feet
taller than I am aye mohabbat compared
to Chris I also work less there's a
thing in the background right there
and there's birds flying I'm just going
to point out every detail I see this is
a tree in the foreground
thank you that that is what there's a
castle or something the caravan stops
for the day a gift says mogart cracking
open Mead casks from our gracious
friends the governor of strand hours
passed with raucous laughter as the meat
is passed throughout camp Costa vagner
toast of ignore you raise your drink
toasting the alliance between man and
oral the others join in Luden's
expression is like a stone wall but the
others laugh at your exaggerations
eventually you sit down beside bogner
chat with vulgar chat with long narrow
thanks for the speech slurs bogner well
before we get into the story I guess
another reminder that we are giving away
free copies of the deluxe edition of
this game comes with the the soundtrack
which as we pointed out Austin Wintory
Austin wintry awesome soundtrack um if
you keep an eye on our twitter feed uh
follow us follow at gamespot follow at
stoic games and if you keep an eye on
our Twitter feed we're gonna mention it
will be following at or you just have to
mention at gamespot at stewart games as
that's st OIC coic gay nose games again
and include the hashtag banner saga for
a chance to win this is me doing the
hashtag symbol hashtag hashtag we're
giving away three copies of the game
this is our second mention there should
be another one coming up really soon so
keep an eye on our Twitter feed to know
when to reply looks like you didn't have
to miss out after all
links to more gear i thought the damned
governor would never shut up like
governor talk did he give you the
history of his entire family he tried
then he asked me to clean up his mess
for your benefit turns out I'm totally
wrong it's not still games so it's at
stoic studio york studio stoic studio oh
that's better thing I'm embarrassing
I've no they're st oh I see stoic so
let's try this one more time so if you
follow at gamespot and you followed at
stoic studio student students to do with
the hashtag banner saga was embarrassing
you'll get a chance to win the game at
stoic studio still game is probably not
even a thing as my key thing they're
gonna get a lot of love all of a sudden
yeah a lot of love for no reason we're
gonna be like why are we getting all
this love at stoic studio and at
gamespot your line my life I'd have
given the job to you too God's there's
no joy in politics all do it speaking of
what happens after this business with
luden hopefully the boy goes back to our
egg on his own and I can take out some
frustration or dredge or something
starting to sound like Hawking you don't
like the life of a diplomat ha don't you
miss the fight to bit you down your meat
instead of reply vogue near slouches
shakes his head
uh we should do a different accidents
you just change it up a little bit
there's no roadster god what the hell is
that but this to share this nonsense I'm
stood between the two killings the force
some kind of lineage
there's three warriors will follow you
for what your dog Manny I you know I
can't you haha you know I they follow
you now listen this is because I'm the
next in line this lines are kidding
mother old viral they're always been
muddy bog near bug near stairs into the
campfire lost and thought you leave him
to it not frost Gaza you rise groggily
the campsite a casualty of merriment mo
gear is already kicking warriors awake
when you spot luden stalking your
direction besides step sleeping bodies
better wake up you nudge fog near you're
needed my fog near yep everybody who's
not that's basically it odds Lydon
always a pleasure you look well-rested
bogna releases the cage Dion and
receives a heart I'd stare in return how
long did Roth I'm
ha we're only two days out of strand you
know come I'll show you on a map you're
really enjoying this out here I like
voices yeah you do laughter look around
blah blah
I clicking and dragging is Matt I loved
the writing I ain't the writing is of
course the Lord of the Rings jr.
token-based his riding on an easel these
ancient Norse signals and runes and
another style writing told him then I am
a big fan of Tolkien okay so someone in
the twitch chat says Justin sounds so
much like crying from the good old days
of TMNT I just got a tingle of Saturday
morning TV nostalgia running about my
loins oh wow that's you also Justin
likes voices he hears so many we had
North that I passed the fort's girl
flames far from strand going to be a
long march from here on my hacking
hacking will be you should have dragged
last night or done why not take the
ships to screamers did what's the point
of marching
you're right yeah thus arose silverstone
Bay's called after reason it stays
covered in ice all year it would tear up
the longships too bad we could have
shown you all the wonders of skymen
Erstad I have something for the crawling
with dredge Prince trans enclosures look
delicious louddon exhales through the
nose a poor disguise for his contempt he
turns it bats aside the tent flaps as he
goes barking at his company in the
distance don't poke the anthill vogner
he seems no happy to be happier to be
here than you spend a few more days with
a boy old friend you'll be looking for a
tall cliff to hop off of Newton's got a
shorter wick that happen thanks boss
partner what's good woman another
hostile to vendor fell a front man I all
these names I'm very very hard to follow
that story I don't know who Hawking is
or Hawkin is the due to the awesome
moustache is the porn stache rahi I know
I know he's the dude on screen but I
don't know that's how you follow okay
Camp camp is where you manage your
Caravan during travel you can enter camp
at any time by clicking the camp button
on the travel HUD while at camp or in
towns you can upgrade your allies or
equip items in the heroes 10 did you
make it this far when you played by it
oh now okay so this is beyond our
evening way beyond so you can pass your
time by using the rest tent resting
improves the caravans morale I'm just
reading with sunscreen high morale will
reduce casualties and more and affect
your willpower and combat each passing
day will use supplies to only rest when
necessary the training tip allows you to
safely try out characters in mock battle
and click leave at the bottom of the
camp site when you're done quickly here
I think it wants you to click the heroes
I think it's telling you something I
think it says to do this is a chance Oh
injured units injuries egg and then put
on the disabled list that dudes injured
sports reference it was stolen wait I
don't have anyone off click on a unit to
view stats promote ranks and learn about
abilities so we're all learning about
what's going on here villa days bring
the pain that is an awesome sounding
ability bring the pain as like a
wrestling move twitch chat s does the
deluxe version of this game include the
voice acting if so all order now
unfortunately this is we've only this
was a special dev build that was sent
exclusively to us I don't think this
voice acting will be in the final build
I think they had to cut it out because
of quality purposes it seems reasonable
it's a how do i upgrade I don't know I
guess you gotta keep fighting so you put
people in your party you oh look you can
see it see that you have the name Syria
packing no I Layton yeah I just yeah I
just I just don't know who they are I
guess you mean as a person like what is
what it means
so I mean what does this one do that's
like it there's a breaking chain and
there's then that nothing happens when
you click on them well you don't have
any points available that's why you
can't upgrade it says right there on the
screen the zero points available so
right now you can't upgrade that guy and
that's I guess the maximum amount that
you can upgrade it to but i did get
promoted during fights if you remember
yes so you're another promotion up i'm
gonna rest it goes
I kind of want to rest
that wrestling that it is that doable
are they wrestling with like a moose or
something like that okay we're gonna get
out here oh so it says well first time
points out of the two extremes see on
the bottom it says you're out of two you
need two more kills to promote edge webs
Oh gasps Oh actual relation wind sweeps
in from the way they tend livestock but
most are just man driven from strand
with nowhere else to go why else would
anyone stay we won't stop long oh
there's so much better than they're all
right all right you're pretty good yeah
no peasant what's it what's a good
peasant was dying bar drug that's lots
of vile for some missing cat
what Oh couple days back soon worth the
stress about the cattle didn't expect an
RV it looks pleased with himself till it
sinks it but you aren't here on his
behalf where if your cattle God wouldn't
know my boys see men up the hills
carrying in the way don't know many men
who could waste a whole cow by himself
whoa Steph looks out for odor cut the
half hour working for them who's moger
ogre that ought to know oh yeah I just
saw a dark soon guy he has the same
voices porn stash back locked from what
the governor told me I'm going to take a
look around and get camp set up the
peasant spits his eyes anxiously darting
about as the caravan sets up his tents
don't blow no more than a DA not solid
offer only friend you've got hundreds
Varl are you serious what I think you
are willing to south
you thinking of squatting not enough
room for a couple hunters here forget
hundreds of oh that was so cops are a
lot for us load up if its fate sounds
like fighting and something else kekkon
takes off at a run you're acting it out
now running is everything Wow oh there's
a fight someone says when they march
across the bottom of the screen it
reminds me of Monty Python and also the
twitch chat says just like in real life
sometimes in order to get a promotion
you have to kill someone with a great
axe dude that guy is huge I don't think
you're gonna win this fight you're not
the dude in the big armored you're the
little guy right like a peasant or
something oh no that's the prince
everyone looks tiny compared to this
dude you have to fight now
what are you doing was I want me to do
deflected attacks do no damage so
apparently this guy can dip like what
you're doing from here on out you will
fail catastrophically if you don't break
his armor how far the hell what the hell
I think you just failed catastrophically
I didn't even knew that that was part of
the training I think that's what was
supposed to happen you were supposed to
die so that you learned that you have to
break his arm that was bad times for me
and I Prince I guess it was mostly bad
times to Prince
so break his armor
there I know there's other dudes they're
not as big though I think you can take
them no not I'm not great bring the
paint out i canna cream and want to you
are gonna go up here don't know are you
sad that you don't have any there's a
little voice acting to be done here this
is a lot more damage I should just do
damage to him then he smacked you 45 so
we're can you see Oh your hip points are
in the left when you click on your hair
maybe
I can do
you know what you're doing yeah I'm
doing that what does that do it does 5
damage to the health down to seven so he
would take tour of damage if he had less
or bird though I guess yeah well now
because he has more armor than he does
spring it's like the percentage actually
hit him goes down a ninety percent yeah
we go then that's how they can deflect
attacks yeah this will knock it down
sound very DVD he's only found the demon
a you're gonna kill this dude another
ninety percent chance you can also see
armors strength by hovering over their
characters and looking at their banner
according to the twitch stream
some are you moving you coward oh he's
doing the wall I have that I had that
thing with oh my god do he's defending
but he's defending the wrong way does it
matter which direction you're facing I
don't thanks I mean that's part of like
I don't think this game is a tactics
game because that would be something in
the tactics gamer I guess in turn based
RPG which are totally different things
yes oh I could do that and then i'll do
a will we're not doing the will power
there we go so do you enjoy the combat
in this what haven't really picked up
yet oh yeah still burger like this is
our like second or third battle yeah
third battle oh yeah someone says that
the Hat reminds him of picked up from
legend of zorro i know who minnows and
while I princess thank for our listeners
my name is by far the best character in
zelda history
I don't even know who number two would
be your favorite Kirk what about it
pullin I mean yeah I guess I mean I like
I like your tone of it you know she's
not not only much of character just
divorce whenever an enemy falls in
battle one will power star is added to
your board using the Longhorn will give
one will power to the active outline I
didn't even notice the horn up there
where's the one at the top at the top
there it is I really gotta like attack
the dude be Fred this is not the best
setting for learning all of everything
that's going on because we have all of
us uh there's a lot of pressure on you
is there to not fail I don't think so i
think people expect me to fail someone
in the twitch stream says don't insult
Tom zelda knowledge he'll go straight up
super saiyan on you well you know i am
not like lauric Anderson who's even know
what his job is but he's one of the
heroes like everything about Zelda I
just I know the games he knows the
characters and stuff so we're going to
be playing for about 10 more minutes do
you think we should mention one last
time I just got a shield master an
achievement bastard do you think we
should mention that you can win the game
how can you win the game so by following
us on Twitter following us being
gamespot if you follow @ symbol gamestop
and at oh you said game stuff gamespot i
said yeah that's a gamespot adds a game
spot and at Stoics to do with the
hashtag Banner Saga you can get enter a
chance to win the digital deluxe version
of banner saga which also comes with the
excellent excellent soundtrack to the
game
these so just keep an eye on our Twitter
feed on the gamespot twitter feed for
your chance to win and remember to
follow at gamespot and at stoic studio
st OIC SCU di o with the hashtag Banner
Saga first chance wit wedding chances
I'm gonna bring some pain bring the pain
that's all did oh did you have enough
that you have a dude fall yeah don't
think it's not permit us I don't think
he fells so much as you I'd though you
have a lot of pressure like he just cuz
it's cold well it is cold they're not
wearing a lot of clothing but I think
those hammers like the stuff we're
carrying is pretty heavy so they're
working up a sweat just moving around
how bit much more painful be to be hit
like a budgeting tool when it's cold out
like your body would just break
promoted motor promoted hakan
you type into the chat I'm typing in the
chat I'm pointing out that I said
gamespot definitely not gamestop okay
trying to get yourself killed booted
what are you doing I was tryin fine
enough trying to get a shot in between
the plates you've never seen a judge boy
before what kind of idiot breaks their
armor for I'll break the armor first
Aaron 88 see you know where did they
come from we didn't even see them they
were just there hacking Goes Down Goes
get hacking goes down never won a can
goes to wear vogner lies faced out the
future viral king lies motionless aside
from spreading pool of blood uh-oh full
gear steed Oh chapter to cut with keen
edge sword that actually might be a good
place to stop that is probably where we
should start to wrap this up yeah that
was really cool I are you excited that
you purchased this already I'm very
excited I'm excited that you helped fund
this game through might start I'm glad
that I have brought something like help
that I'm one of the guys that get help
to bring this nice oh god it looks so
good I love just looking at this game
that is a really cool art show well I
want to go home and try it out oh yeah I
just want to thank thank you too for
everyone to tune in because we couldn't
do this stuff if you guys didn't tune in
and thanks to Eric A&M horik who are
behind the scenes getting everything to
work and Justin hable for joining me um
and then come back to this very stream
in one hour when we will be doing a very
special spelunky daily challenge not you
not me because I'm really bad at
splinters waters and Sean McKenna's and
me Thomas J but until then uh see hahaha
you